hey what's going on it's bill bro and it
is the Monday morning podcast from
Monday February 8th 2010 one day after
Super Bowl 44 well usually I don't begin
my podcast with a warning but I'm going
to this week if you live anywhere near
Indianapolis you want to shut this thing
off right now okay if you're one of
those fantasy football playing
douchebags with your stats and your
peyton manning poster hanging above your
[ __ ] bed you want to shut this thing
off right now alright because this
podcast is dedicated to you guys you
[ __ ] [ __ ] who I've been telling you
for the last five [ __ ] years that
Peyton Manning is overrated I even went
off on him last week
last week I went off on that guy you
cannot believe the emails that I got
from people all just [ __ ] not only
defending Peyton Manning but brushing
off Tom Brady and his three Super Bowl
rings as if oh you can plug anybody into
that system you know but Peyton man Oh
Peyton Manning who Peyton Manning he
threw he threw for 50 [ __ ] touchdowns
during what he threw five touchdowns
against the [ __ ] Buccaneers in
November I said it last week Peyton
Manning is a regular-season statistical
juggernaut all right if you want to know
who the [ __ ] that guy is if you're still
confused the [ __ ] is there an invasion
you hear that [ __ ] that's what happens
out here in [ __ ] la so many prob be
knee install they go a little overboard
out here um dude I'm telling you right
now if you want to know who Peyton
Manning is you want to know that [ __ ]
guy is picture this if Dan Marino [ __ ]
Brett Favre their baby would be Peyton
Manning that's who he is
okay in this [ __ ] had only won one
[ __ ] time his whole career and all
these analysts on TV was ridiculous
they're all going you know I'm telling
you right now you know if he wins here
you're arguably looking at one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time
because of what based on what
based on what his regular-season stats
this guy [ __ ] chokes every year in
the [ __ ] playoffs he's only won once
he's only won once and everybody's just
[ __ ] talking about and all you
[ __ ] who [ __ ] emailed me this
week where you emails now huh mailed
each one of you every one of you [ __ ]
back and I never heard it from you you
know maybe it's still [ __ ] stunned
maybe you still [ __ ] confuse so you
know what you know what I'm gonna do
just for all you [ __ ] idiots out
there who think that Peyton Manning is
the greatest [ __ ] guy ever totally
disrespecting Tom Brady Tom Brady has to
wear it you know like he has to wear a
[ __ ] welder's mask at night to go to
sleep that's how [ __ ] bright his room
is from those three championship rings
and you guys still disrespect him the
analysts on TV still disrespect them
they never talk about him the way they
talk about Peyton Manning all that
counts is what the [ __ ] you do in
January you know nobody talks about
Terry Bradshaw you guys haven't watched
Super Bowl 10 it's up on [ __ ] YouTube
watch that game Terry Bradshaw if you
looked at his numbers you [ __ ] stat
boy [ __ ] if you looked at his numbers
on paper you wouldn't think the guy was
[ __ ] he'd be little Payton mini usually
twice as good as this guy he's closing
in on 50,000 yards all Bradshaw has is
25 thousand yards yeah in four [ __ ]
rings Superbowl ten Terry Bradshaw fades
back to pass in the fourth [ __ ]
quarter gets knocked unconscious gets a
concussion okay and on that play that he
got a concussion
he throws a 50-yard strike to Lynn Swann
for the go-ahead [ __ ] score all right
that's what the great ones do and nobody
ever brings up Terry Bradshaw what the
[ __ ] has he ever done but other than win
four [ __ ] Super Bowls so just in case
you guys are still confused about your
boy Peyton Manning I'm gonna read you
some of his stats the stats that [ __ ]
count all right here we go the greatest
quarterback of all time I got a little
music for you this week all right
December 30th such an obnoxious ass
this is Carly Simon by the way singing
nobody does it better you know this is
what all the analysts have been singing
for the last [ __ ] 10 years of this
guy's career December 30th
all right kicks ass in the regular
season
dolphins beat the Colts 23:17 overtime
wild card game oh whatever
whatever that's his first trip to the
playoffs he'll get better 2002 Colts
lose 41 nothing in a playoff route
against the New York Jets J ETS Jets
Jets Jets this is the greatest
quarterback of all [ __ ] time
potentially with one [ __ ] ring
everybody tuned in and watched and see
how he does against the Saints let's
look how he did January 8 2004 Colts
lose 24 14 to the New England Patriots
greatest [ __ ] quarterback potentially
if ever one [ __ ] ring you see his foot
look he's unbelievable okay his hand-eye
coordination
he's got the pedigree January 16 2005
Colts again lose to the Patriots 22 3
greatest [ __ ] quarterback of all
[ __ ] time January 15 2006 Colts lose
to the Steelers 21 to 18 greatest
quarterback of all time
and right around then people start going
oh is this another Dan Marino but no the
next year he finally [ __ ] shows up
finally grows a dick comes back 21
points down against the Patriots wins
his first Super Bowl and then I'm
thinking ok he's a [ __ ] man now right
I'm gonna see some Montana [ __ ] I'm
gonna see some some [ __ ] Terry
Bradshaw I'm gonna see sometimes [ __ ]
Brady what's he do the next year he
loses at home to the San Diego Chargers
alright
maybe he had a [ __ ] hangover maybe
had a [ __ ] hangover what's he doing
the next year greatest quarter [ __ ]
quarterback ever loses to the eighth
Nate Chargers at [ __ ] home
right and here the Sun this is what
these [ __ ] analysts has been just
continue to sing he's the new Brett
Favre Brett Favre can do no wrong
throws against his body over the [ __ ]
middle and what his Tom Jackson say well
you know he's never been afraid to lose
the game he [ __ ] blew it
he mushed those Vikings purple nuts
right into the [ __ ] ground and
they're still [ __ ] rubbing his
goddamn Mississippi Kaka
I'm sick of it so here you go he goes up
against the lowly Saints they've never
won a [ __ ] thing in 40 [ __ ] years
of being in the league what's gonna be
the difference Peyton Manning I'll tell
you I got to go with Peyton Manning Oh
Peyton Manning sis Peyton Manning set
Peyton Manning lost the [ __ ] game
yesterday the final drive I got a
question for you Indianapolis fans says
Tom Brady throw a pick six at the end of
the Super Bowl does Joe Montana throw a
[ __ ] pick six does Terry Bradshaw
does Ben Roethlisberger one of the most
overlooked quarterbacks of all time
sitting at home with [ __ ] two rings
does he know he doesn't all right so
[ __ ] all you [ __ ] idiots out in
Indianapolis there you go how was that
did you like that write me a [ __ ] ass
god bless the Saints everybody huh
you